hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to : now this is a newly
released in the horror game that is
supposedly getting fantastic reviews
it's made by someone some developer
outside of the US I'm not exactly sure
because they didn't do a lot of research
on it it just came out on Steam and I
was like years ago Russia the northern
Ural Mountains a group of nine students
of the aural Polytechnic Institute
embarked upon a difficult winter
expedition to reach the otorten mountain
really your Turin mountain my favorite
manager nee seemed to progress according
to plan however on the seventh day of
their trip the weather conditions
worsened they lost their orientation and
were forced to set up a camp on the
slope of the mountain called coal at
ciacco that's my favorite mountain their
last stop Oh No
all the weeks later in Yekaterinburg
when their families received no word of
their success the first rescue
expeditions were sent I know what this
is about On February 25th 1959 an
abandoned encampment was found the tent
was torn down and covered with snow with
all the group's belongings left inside
further examination revealed it was cut
from inside out the surrounding
footprints indicated the crew had fled
at the tent they were barefooted this
suggests a frantic escape characteristic
of people scared out of their wit's two
sets of prints led to a forested area
down the slope the rescue team found an
improvised fireplace and two bodies they
were lying in but their underwear with
cuts and scratches to their limbs
suggesting they had tried to climb the
tree in panic
what could terrify them so much the next
three bodies were found scattered a few
hundred meters from the first discovery
one of them had suffered a fractured
skull this despite no evidence of a
struggle
it took the spring thaw two months later
to enable the rescue team to find the
rest of the victims the last four skiers
were found buried in a thick layer of
ice and snow their autopsies led to even
more bizarre findings all of the bodies
had severe internal injuries caused by
an undetermined force similar to that of
a serious car accident no external
damage nor bruises were visible besides
a tongue ripped from one victim's mouth
and a strange orange skin color much
speculation arose from these puzzling
events such theories included attack
from the local tribesmen from an
avalanche or animals each theory however
only served to create more questions the
truth behind this tragic course of
events remains unexplained
to this day what really happened I know
maybe the answer still waits to be
discovered no peep under the snow
probably not okay this is this is
actually based on a true story that's
not exposition there that's a real story
that happened in Russia it's one of like
the greatest mysteries of whatever
happened to these survivors so oh this
is so pretty oh this is beautiful
now what I say that this is like an
indie horror game that was released on
Steam is like a full-fledged indie
horror game that's supposed to be really
really good and this why it impressed me
because it actually looked pretty good
when I was getting a gander at it on
Steam and then I immediately bought it
and immediately started recording it so
I'm going into this with nothing known
but I do know what that story is
literally it's exactly as it said in a
camp in Russia somewhere
got eviscerated and no one knows why
there's really no explanation for and
oddly enough it ties in to who think a
little bit if you know about the thing
the thing is a really good movie like I
think there's three moves in total there
was a recent um not quite remake but
like a prequel or something I'm not
exactly sure where it's it's in the
timeline it's been a while since I
watched but the fake movies are awesome
because they are phenomenal horror
movies and this is really beautiful to
go I like this it's so haunting Lee
serene in these snowy hills it's really
cool actually it really sets like a
theme I don't know who I am and I don't
know what I'm doing am I supposed to be
exploring like the town or something
because I definitely wasn't doing that
anyone want to give me some supplies
maybe a warm sweater please please I'm
begging you dying
oh you fenced in your entire house you
don't want neighbors obviously I should
probably just continue on yeah going
headfirst into the increasingly bad
storm is probably the best move for me
about going the right way because I'm
not sure what I'm supposed to be doing
besides enjoying the hauntingly
beautiful music and that's a good thing
like I love hauntingly beautiful music
it's something that actually relaxes me
except not what it's terrifying me but
it's something like I find I find
something's changing
the hauntingly beautiful music stopped
I'm just lost in the woods okay it's
kind of like Quentin I was playing among
him asleep and I was just wandering
around like a baby in the woods oh that
looks good huh should I go towards there
was more open or in the pine trees of
death I really wonder where the game
wants to send me oh yeah this is where
the string quartet isn't who no yes
maybe I don't know I don't know you buy
me dinner first pick the good path the
whole world seems to be caving I really
wonder if this is the accurate landscape
of where this is like the trees are just
kind of curved in on this path Oh God a
cave create exactly what I wanted so
what do you have in store for me down
here nightmares
I hope it's nightmares oh wow everything
okay I fell mark he fell down go boom in
the end I saw an idiot falling down for
a boat turning lines I didn't know I'm
markiplier like wings out and I'm
vanished okay I don't I'd rather be
alive thank you very much oh I was
wondering
Oh press e why not what am I gonna take
a nappy new [ __ ] you know huh no you're
not
I don't know who you think you am but um
it's not right behind me that's for damn
sure good thing I got the jiggling
compass way better than those standard
actually pointed North compasses using
the fast travel and can't save the pro
how big is this game I actually have no
idea how big this game is this might be
my next long let's play if this game is
actually substantially big Oh act 2
already okay maybe a little bit you
don't think of me that way do you
okay
who's that Sean Bean dude this game is
awesome
holy crap this game is amazing I love
this oh this is such a perfect
introduction press f1 for survival info
left ship Indies nose blabla is tiring
adjust the pace whoa
focus with the right mouse button
flashlight with fm4 map c4 compass oh my
god holy crap this is so cool and it's
awesome I'm gonna die so badly
everyone's gonna have a chance to kill
me okay right mouse to focus on objects
c4 compass oh good it's not spinning
like a maniac at least I'll know where I
am damn for map oh man that's so cool
wait I can't see that though how do I
wait do I have to hold it down
no oh hi you what are you where are you
red and glowing am I in the real world
anymore oh I should go towards this is
probably good so oh hey let's go in
demonic symbol I'll just pick you up why
not
I set at the moment I heard about the
incident I was in the area so I reported
to the unit myself to be automatically
assigned to the case ah I arrived a
devii shy on February the 19th a couple
of days before the Institute's rescue
group while waiting for them I started
asking around to see if anyone from
among the locals knew anything about the
incident one of them said he had a
hunting cabin in the surgeon
you the area very well I decided to use
him as a guard when the rescue team had
finally arrived I explained to them what
the unit's role was in this mission and
that all discoveries of observation
should be brought to my attention before
anyone elses we establish priorities
check the equipment and set off right
away it was not until February the 26th
we found the tent that I believe
belonged to the students initial
findings showed that the people in the
tent cut its sidewall and for some
reason tried to escape from it in panic
the tracks in the snow led to a forest
two kilometre and a half away but the
trail went cold after 500 meters and we
had to carefully search the entire area
this was not a place of any average
incident we had shivers crawling all
over our bodies because of the
atmosphere surrounding us I was
convinced that something more than just
an accident had occurred here I had the
feeling we were dealing with something
unnatural
thank you for I died what do you mean I
died I was watching the light show oh I
didn't know I was about to die I had a
funny feeling baby I don't know well I'm
dumb that's what I do when I'm in a
panic situation I immediately stand in
the center of everything that's going
horribly and then I just look at my
death as it comes rushing towards me
okay that's so cool it's great how I'm
not dead oh hey oh hi hi who are you why
are you what are you doing okay
did I mention how cool this game was my
god it's awesome what the hell is going
on
what's so intrigued by everything that's
happening around me right I guess I need
to run up towards this guy or wherever
this guy's going
this game does a great job of like
telling me where I'm going because I
went into this not knowing anything at
all I'm very fatigued now but I went
into this not knowing anything at all
but now like I have a very clear sense
of direction of where I'm going in and
this going into it with nothing even
though I died obviously that was my own
stupidity looking up with the light show
it's not a UFO please prove me the poop
anyway so like that was obviously my
fault but what isn't my fault is the
fact that this game is very good at
establishing the setting like god I'm so
into this who's so into this I'm suing
not being creepy I get excited because I
play so many of these you know not
professionally made any mortgage please
don't
I'm I'd like to think of myself as
pleasantly average okay thanks
that's a lot of reassuring words but you
said it in a reassuring not way I can't
even say words right so maybe I'll just
leave it up to you where is it going
black oh it's literally just going black
I thought I was blacking out oh is that
a wolfy oh hello life and snow
hello Oh am I not supposed to go this
way it seems like there's an impassable
wall oh the cave okay the cave all right
why not
it's gonna happen to me what kind of a
vomit above snow man it's gonna murder
me this time okay anyway like I was
saying a while back about the thing the
thing is actually a really really cool
movie and if you haven't seen it already
I would highly recommend you girls go
watch it if you want nightmares or
whatever it's it's a horror movie
wait what back through here hey where's
my guide I was just talking about how
great the navigation of this was now I'm
lost
Oh in there well that looks like a big
cave I'm gonna go in there I'm gonna go
very much in there it's got icicles like
teeth I bet there's all sorts of things
about to give me a hug yep just as nice
as I had hoped they gonna move here my
next move
how about a markiplier new home tour
from in here anyway that they got
gigabit internet
okay I really hope I am going the right
way because I might just be backtracking
like an idiot oh man it's like a free
roam exploration I really don't know if
this is the proper way that I was
supposed to go it seems okay unless for
some reason again I just looped around
in a big circle because I'm assuming oh
I have a map duh
wait why can't I look at them oh I have
to stop moving so where I am oh oh cool
cool cool that's exactly what I needed
thank you okay so I meant I meant 27
north 52 east so 27 north 27 north 52
ease so I'm right here
okay so I'm not far from my camp where
am i I'm supposed to go here I know
that's where the first landmark was so I
need to go to the one nearby in to me
I'm at 52 East so if I go north north
oh no yeah I'm gonna
who's that thank you goodbye are you
okay uh yeah okay this is the way to go
this is the way to go okay I'm going the
right way
minor navigational difficulties but
mostly just because of how incredibly
intelligent I am okay so if I just keeps
heading north I should hit exactly where
I need to go this game is so cool it's
so cool I love everything about this
hear that rustling
oh it was okay there was rustling okay
cool oh I get to read this mysterious
lights above this fall botany Cosmodrome
mysterious events in the sky were noted
during the night of 4 to 5 July
witnesses testified they had seen a
bright orange sphere which had crossed
the sky above the several cities several
times moving chaotically and immediately
changing its direction of flight finally
it stopped and disappeared
major Gierke an aviation professional
confirms it is possible for any flying
object we know to move like that oh it's
impossible the military and cosmodromes
personnel answered our questions in a
short and firm way by distancing
themselves from to the event informing
there was no activity in that area as
well as there were no tests performed
Wow could there be I think maybe
absolutely yes okay so in the future I
need to be on the lookout or on the ear
out for the rustling sound because
that's the sound of papers being Jimmy
jangled all over the place I need to
find there also like clues as to where I
can go but I think this is a correct
path to get up this mountain at least
going north and this was the way I was
going before at least I found another
note so it's not totally useless okay I
think I'm onto something wind is
whipping with increased intensity I'm
going north what is that what is that
oh that's a fire holy [ __ ] is someone
else here I don't think that's a good
thing and also I'm crossing a frozen
lake which is where I'm supposed to be
not sure that's what I wanted those are
their fires why would there be fires I
mean that's a good indicator where I
need to go but why are there
fires oh hey hello flame guy girl flame
thing flame person no at the beginning I
wanted to make things right so why
didn't you
I believed God itself touched me well
that's a strange thing to say that I
saved a chance a compensation for the
evil that was brought upon me
I understood that it is not God or good
or restitution okay yeah that sounds
about right
you have a rather bleak outlook on life
maybe you need to pep up a little bit
relax you know consumer to the five
nights at Freddy's animatronics they
really know how to relax after I told
about the old good bones great okay
cannibalism is that what I'm gonna
experience here is this like the other
the opposite of the island from stranded
or not stranded deep the forest where
it's just a different kind of cannibals
coming to me no maybe I don't know I
don't know you weirdo stop Oh No good
let's go well surprisingly nothing
happened okay
oh where am I now am I supposed to be
good oh great is that death is that
gonna kill me they're gonna kill me also
as well approach didn't go now
yeah Bram that's death okay cool great
lovely how that happened can that not
happen again but I'm obviously going the
right way because there was the person
use me mister ronk okay hello you're
adorable
terrifying
oh this gold all this water okay well
damn it I didn't know that was gonna be
like that
Nikes how far back is got gonna set me I
had no idea ah tits where am I
I have no idea where I am dammit alright
so anyway that's all the time I have to
play this one I'm gonna play a lot more
of this game let me know what you think
of its in the comments below it's a very
new release and you also you can try for
yourself it's on Steam right now but
this is looking really promising
oh I'm where I am where I picked up that
note so thank you everybody so much for
watching in the next episode I'll pick
it up where I left off so thanks again
everyone and as always I will see you in
the next video
oh okay